there are thousands of these generators
across a country that's on the edge of
collapse people are sourcing their own
power at least those who can afford it
the state electricity company is
providing one hour of power a day as the
hard currency reserves needed to import
fuel are dwindling the crisis is taking
a toll on people's livelihoods
we need electricity if we're to sell ice
cream and other refreshments but i can't
pay for a generator i lost my customers
at the end of the day will be forced to
close the shop
lebanon's leaders hope a deal to import
natural gas from egypt will allow four
hours of electricity to be generated a
day it's part of a government plan that
also includes purchasing electricity
from jordan
but these deals won't come into effect
right away u.s sanctions on the
government in damascus need to be waived
gas and electricity need to transit
through syria
we hope to get the final guarantees from
the u.s concerning the sanctions the u.s
and the international community's
support are essential so that this
project is implemented
the u.s has said it will evaluate the
deal once it is signed before deciding
on whether it violates sanctions but
another obstacle is funding money has
not been secured from the world bank
which is demanding conditions like an
audit of the electricity company
the electricity infrastructure was
devastated during the civil war since it
ended in 1990 lebanon has not had
continuous supply of electricity
successive governments have failed to
rebuild the sector or come up with a
sustainable energy strategy
and that's added tens of billions of
dollars to the country's massive public
debt
corruption is endemic in many state
institutions
it's not only about getting the same
machines or building a plan to generate
electricity you have to think about all
the supply chain all the services
related deals that were assigned to
benefit certain per individual or
certain political party the deals with
egypt and jordan are part of a
government plan to provide 24-hour power
by 2026
but previous plans have gone
unimplemented due to political wrangling
or the lack of will to reform that runs
against the interests of those in power
senator al-jazeera beirut